just to see steven strasburg it's the
pitching equivalent
to seeing juan soto back in the lineup
yeah mary strassmas to everybody out
there
opening day for steven strasburg today
up the middle
to the bag castro for a 4-3
double play lead-off hit no problem
the 31-year-old right-hander asher
wojciechowski see what he's done on the
season so far 0-2 with a 5-4 era
he's worked in 10 innings punched out
11. only walked three along the way
oh emergency hack there that one was in
the catcher's mitt neaton just kind of
flipped the bat out there
that's not a swing he'd be too proud of
no it's obviously a pitching he tries to
lay off of it at the last second he
has no idea why he swings at that the
ball just kept coming up on him it
looked like him
that's one of those ones you go back dug
out just shaking your head jakowski
ready the 1-2 pitch
got him locked him up and then you said
that first inning was key he breathes he
looks good huh
top of the second inning here at
nationals park no score
got him change up nasty first strikeout
great pitch count through two innings
strasbourg
back and efficient juan soto leads off
for the nationals
soto off to a four for 11 start 364 with
a double a homer two rbis
in his first three games a hot start for
juan soto
and that ball is scorched out to left
with some carry on it
no chance for dwight smith and juan soto
looks like he's been hitting for a month
he's now five out of 12 with three extra
base hits
the two doubles and the homer have all
gone the other way this is a laser
a laser we have a spinning slider
107 mile an hour double for juan soto i
mean this was over his head the second
he touched it at home plate
so there goes the no hitter on soto with
a lead off double here in the second
what new and that'll load them up for
michael a2
so they were first and third nobody out
now they're loaded with two outs
rojokowski the taylor
hit well deep center field hayes is back
on the track
and makes the catch wow now you can
breathe mojo
that's retired no score after two
hayes down to the count 0-2
hit hard right field there's a base hit
eaton knocks it down austin hayes is on
with one down
that's hit to right field base hit
cisco's on board hayes goes into second
so three hard hit balls in this inning
remember dwight smith
hit a bullet out to the left field for
the first out and then back to back hits
from hayes
and now cisco 3-0 nearly hit him
and he shakes he shakes the right hand
again 1-2
holiday hits one on a line out to right
that's down for a base hit
hayes scores they will give the stop
sign to cisco at third base throw goes
back in there
cisco is safe holiday comes with an rbi
single with two strikes against him in
the orioles with a one-nothing lead of
the fifth
they get one in and now alberto with the
bag still full
hit hard it's into left field this will
score at least two
cisco's home bobbled out there by soto
felika's home
and the orioles have jumped on top three
to nothing
two rbis on the double from hancer
alberto
and the orioles are getting to strasberg
here in the fifth
3-1 on the way hit hard into left field
that could score two
holidays home it will two rbis
anthony santander continues to deliver
14 rbis on the year now and the orioles
have jumped
on strasbourg for five in the inning and
that's going to end his afternoon
castro hit it hard up the middle last
time oh my
separate this see you
later pnc
he parked one and it's a five to two
game
castro's first as in that over the
bullpen landing halfway up
section 102. bang
zoom goes starlin castro with his first
home run in the nationals uniform
it's a two out two run shot here at the
bottom of the fifth inning
and the nationals are on the board it's
baltimore five and washington two he
parked it
and now we dance
[Applause]
it's really coming down now huge drops
like i said it's gonna miss us
yeah and laz diaz gonna get everybody
off the field right now
at 2 40 p.m
ground screw going to work in a hurry
here we've got heavy rain
it's blowing almost at a 45 degree angle
coming in from the west
this is serious the way it's raining
they got to get that tarp out there this
one's over
and it is really coming down yeah that
tarp
not unrolling smoothly at all you know
as they started rolling it out right
there you could tell something
was wrong and at one point it was going
out and coming in at the same time that
makes any sense
that's never good and that's what was
going on it rained really hard for about
10 minutes time
the orioles and nationals game has been
suspended after
a long delay the rain came in at 240
field in tough shape and we just got
word there it is
according to mlb rules the game
suspended will resume on friday august
14th
the game was suspended but ben and i
haven't been suspended we're back here
to conclude this one and the orioles
have a chance to sweep again
two sweeps in two days ben so finnigan
will be on the mound valeeka at the
plate dwight smith walks out to second
base
so we're ready ready to resume five two
orioles
lake of fly ball center field fairly
deep
smith tags taylor makes the catch and
he'll advance to third
follow the strike two down two on to the
right side
and gloved by star castro and he can't
get rid of it in the original score run
an
infield hit rbi for catcher brian
holliday
and the orioles tack on a run and make
it 6-2
there's a base hit game still alive
crown first heading for two is taylor
and it's a double
with two down here in the bottom of the
nine
one-two pitch to eaton this should do it
bounce to alberto the flip underhand and
the orioles have a win
six to two givens closes it out
birds sweep the nationals and they've
won six in a row